- [Announcer] This Great Big
Story was made possible by IBM.
(birds chirping)
(children chattering)
(inspiring music)
- Every child is a scientist,
and just like everywhere in the world,
every child in Africa is very curious,
likes to experiment, likes to discover.
Imagine every single student
on the African continent
having their own science lab
with the microscopes and
then the circuit boards
and carrying that science lab
with them everywhere they go.
(inspiring music)
I'm Charles Ofori Antipem.
I'm 26 years old; I'm a scientist,
and some people call me The Mad Scientist.
- [Narrator] He might be mad,
but he sure is brilliant.
To tackle the lack of
science education in Ghana,
Charles and his team took a science lab
and just kind of shrunk it.
- Back in 2015, my
co-founder Michael and I
really wanted to find a solution
and that was when we
built the first prototype
of the Science Set.
The Science Set is a
lab that is small enough
that it can fit on the desk of a student
and affordable enough that every student
can simply have one.
The Science Set currently costs $20.
It has close to 45 individual
components inside it;
and those students can use to perform
a wide variety of activities.
(children chattering)
- [Woman] Good, clap for ourselves.
(clapping)
Now, the second activity ...
- I can even use the Science Set
or anything in the Science Set
to make anything that can help people.
- I use it to do my homework.
- You can use it to make also things like
a security detector, an alarm.
(devices beeping)
- One of the really exciting
things that we've seen is
when you give students
access to these tools,
and then they understand
the concepts really well,
these students begin to innovate.
One of such examples is a
student called Princess.
She didn't have access to electricity.
After using the Science Set and learning
about electrical circuits, she
came up with her light box.
And now four of her friends
can come to her house,
and they can collaborate
on their homework.
(inspiring music)
- [Narrator] While the dream
is big for this mad scientist,
up next is something
actually pretty small.
- [Charles] We are creating a microscope
that costs us a little
less than five dollars.
The idea for the microscope
is to be able to use
really affordable materials
to be able to create something
that can magnify up to about 10x to 45x,
so the students can view onion
cells and things like that.
It's humbling, I would say;
it feels very humbling to see
students use the Science Set.
We believe that in the
not too distant future
we're gonna have really,
really awesome scientists
coming from Africa.
(children chattering and clapping)
(soft piano music)
(electronic tones)